hi i'm ed helms i'm jana schmeeding and
i'm super excited to share the trailer
for my new show rutherford falls
plus stick around after to learn a
little more about the show
400 years ago my patriarchal ancestor
lawrence rutherford founded our town
anyone see the resemblance i definitely
see it it's in the jaw
shoulders through the chest and probably
some other places
okay thank you i
am the steward of my family's legacy
that will resonate throughout history
and you have a museum you're gonna get
yours too
this is a ginormous casino but nobody
wants to help my cultural center the
only native artifacts in here are those
bangs
you seem smart i'm guessing lots of
college not ivy league
but so close it drives you crazy
northwestern
nathan i'm calling to request a response
to mayor chisenhall's decision to move
big larry i'm sorry what
the problem is not big larry it's the
road
this is the fifth time someone's crashed
into that statute it's a public safety
issue it's history deirdre you can't
change history unless you have a time
machine
and you don't because if you did you'd
go back and tell yourself not to buy
that blazer
what i'm gonna get this town on my side
and i'm gonna transform my cultural
[Music]
center
this town has forgotten how to honor
their ancestors we focus on the problems
that are actually important well big
larry's important
more important than the opioid crisis
apples and oranges carla
there's something happening in that town
this is a story about
stories damn the podcasting
voice is very manipulative
so much drama but let's uh leave them
okay
no but i'm not done telling these people
why they're wrong and stupid
this is why it's not worth being friends
with white people no
[Music]
hi i'm ed helms i'm janice meeting i'm
jesse lee i'm michael grahas
i'm dustin milligan and here's what you
should know about
rutherford falls
[Music]
rutherford falls is a show about a man
nathan
rutherford who lives in a town that
literally bears his last name because
his forefathers founded the town 400
years ago
anyone see the resemblance he takes a
lot of pride in the
town and in his family and maybe has
some blind spots
about his uh family lineage fun fact i'm
actually the last rutherford
to live here in rutherford falls his
best friend is a woman named regan who's
played by
jenna schmiding and she is a member of
the fictional
minnesota native tribe and the show is
really about their friendship
and about what happens in
their lives and in the town when there's
a
minor kerfuffle over a statue of
nathan's ancestor
rutherford falls is uh a creation
of mike shurer sierra teller or nellis
and myself
mike sure has done amazing stuff i
worked with him on the office of course
then he went on to
create parks and recreation and then
co-create
brooklyn nine-nine then the good place
and just
so much awesome television and sierra
has worked on brooklyn nine-nine and
superstore and
this show really fits into that kind of
zone of um
of an ensemble comedy ed helms also a
co-creator of this show
is probably one of the funniest people
i've ever met and
also just one of the nicest people in in
anywhere really
when we started rutherford falls we
wanted to be smart and funny
and i'm really i'm really proud of the
show we've made if you
love any or all of these shows i think
you're gonna feel
right at home on rutherford falls
i think the comedy in the show is uh is
is warm-hearted and earnest
sorry i get very sweaty when i'm
confident but also pretty biting at
times you can't change history
unless you got a time machine and you
don't because if you did you'd go back
in time and tell yourself not to buy
that blazer yeah
whoa whoa bobby coming in a little hot
there that's a sick burn now
it feels very grounded uh but in the
same way that
real life can get super silly and weird
sometimes
so does the show oh it's dehydrated
the tone of the show it's it's very
smart comedy in that
it weaves in authentic and unique
stories
that people at home anywhere can
identify with
i wish i could count the jokes
per minute they come fast
they hit hard you seem smart i'm
guessing lots of college
not ivy league but so close it drives
you
crazy northwestern everybody gets jokes
on the show
it's a great time go gamble away your
401ks
it's also a comedy about real
lives uh including real native
lives
[Music]
this show is one of the first of its
kind it has
um a writing staff that is half native
half non-native
i've worked in television for 10 years
and i've never worked with another
native writer until their show
we had five native voices in the writers
room
and uh that creates a world
where native people who are
very funny in our daily lives are now
funny on screen the only native
artifacts in here
are those bangs we had native writers
from all over the country
um so it's not any one kind of point of
view i think that the
the sort of influence or the the sort of
mixing into the pot of
of the native point of view really makes
this show special and different
[Music]
this show features a really diverse cast
starring michael gray eyes
this is all i can share janusz meeting
well i'm flattered and of course
in what world is vandalism funny we see
a diversity of
native characters and a diversity of of
non-native characters
i remember one day i was on the set and
i was working with uh
jessie lee and i said to jesse our
communities communities of color
never really been featured in
mainstream shows and i actually noticed
that
all the main characters around nathan
were all actors of color
and it really struck me i said this show
is really going
in um uncharted territories
um with how it's mixing its casts and
how
it's allowing diverse voices to really
really be heard
i'm proud of that
this show manages to somehow handle
kind of heavy subject matter but does so
in a very lighthearted
and heartwarming way that statue is core
to who i am
and if it can just be picked up and
tossed around willy-nilly
with no regard for its historical
specificity
then literally who am i what you're
describing
is my entire life which i think is is a
reflection of the world right now we all
want to laugh
we all want to love we all want to live
love
laugh but there's also you know there's
some real stuff that we got to deal with
at the same time
and i think uh what better way than to
gather the family around
the hearth the hearth where the tv is
and watch rutherford falls together so
you can
live love laugh about things that affect
all of us
in a really important and significant
way did i say live love laugh enough
live love life live love laugh the most
important thing to know
check out rutherford falls streaming now
on peacock
okay everyone that concludes our tour
and now our museum associate director
slash intern bobby yang will hand out
some complimentary astronaut ice cream
you